what up reject nation it's your girl sally
aka sally lamonico aka salamander but you can
only call me salamander if you subscribe to this
channel so hit that red subscribe button or else
we are not on a nickname basis you need to earn
it and my love and affection if this is your first
video on this channel that you are watching
hi this video is part of a series where i am
going to be watching all of the marvel movies
in order from phases one through four because
i have not seen most of the newer ones i'm a
nerd when it comes to this stuff i feel stupid
so this week we are watching captain america
the first avenger i don't really know why
this isn't the first one to be
quite honest maybe just didn't
fit well like maybe they try to do ironman first
i don't know this to me should have been the first
one i'm confusion i'm confusion and it obviously
takes place during world war one or two or it's
i'm sorry i'm i swear i'm not stupid i'm horrible
with dates honestly speaking of dates if you want
to watch my full reaction of this movie please go
to patreon.com the real rejects it would be a date
because we're technically sitting down watching a
full movie together and you know why wouldn't you
want to go on a date with me so grab some popcorn
if at any point you laughed during this video or
had a similar reaction or you just enjoyed it and
want to help us out please give a like it really
does help the algorithm it's free not a lot of
things are free in america apparently also quick
shout out to prepper y'all are the homies for
editing together a super long video for highlights
specifically thank you so much it's a lot of work
and i'm just watching the movie ironically it is
july 4th weekend and even though things are not
looking great in america right now i just want
to say happy fourth of july even though this
is coming out probably a month after all right
america
what is my god this one's waited long enough
he didn't even try to move
four guys couldn't open that but he could
the tesseract was the jewel
of odin's treasure room
uh
it's kind of symbolic it's not for
the eyes of ordinary men exactly
the order to open fire fool you cannot control
the power you hold you will burn okay that's
dark disney lord sorry son look just give me a
chance you'll be ineligible on your asthma alone
is there anything you can do i'm doing it
i'm saving your life they should have made
his voice like sound like i hadn't hit puberty
yet because it looks so weird with him talking
that deep and he's just tiny i don't know i don't
know when to give up do you hang on this all day
hey pick on somebody your own size
he kicked his ass like his mama come on man well
last night i gotta get you cleaned up why where
are we going future welcome to the modern
marbles pavilion and the world know tomorrow
a greater world this reminds
me of tomorrowland at disney
imagine being that extra
what if i told you that in just a few short years
your automobile won't even have to touch the
ground at all with stock rubidic reversion
technology you'll be able to do just that
we still don't have cars like that so many
important jobs somebody do collect scrap
yes come on there are men laying down their
lives i got no right to do any less than them
that's what you don't understand don't
do anything stupid until i get back
how can i taking all the stupid with you oh
represent the strategic scientific reserve
steve rogers do you want to kill nazis
i don't want to kill anyone i don't like
bullies i don't care where they're from
well there are already so many big men
fighting maybe what we need now it's a little
guy that's offensive gentlemen i'm agent carter
i supervise all operations for this division
must be the accent queen victoria thought i
was signing up for the us arms i got a few moves i
know you'll like thank god he needed to be punched
that flag means we're only at the halfway point
that's me nobody's got that flag in 17
years let's go get back in the formation
rogers i said fall in
that's the way to do it hodge
passed every test we gave him
he's big he's fast he obeys orders he's
a soldier he's a bully you win wars guts
my god get away get back back
is this a test no [__]
it's a test he's still skinny
yeah that's intimidating for sure
somebody get that kitty sandwiched
comfortable
it's a little big his head is so big two
one
they couldn't have done it slower oh my lord
oh no
we will proceed that's 10
um
oh my god
it's the stock
and he comes out looking like a snake
consent
no not german stanley tucci
respect your elders
nice
uh
no
go
that kid is a trooper
oh that's a whole lot of nope from me
who the hell are you the first of
many cut off one hit hill hydra
okay i did understand that
greek mythology reference
now he's like oh look what i just did with my
new muscles hydra is assembling an arsenal to
destroy my enemies in one stroke wherever they
are regardless of how many forces they possess
quite simply gentlemen i have harnessed
the power of thoughts thank you schmidt
berlin is on this map let's do this
sorry if you're going at the schmidt i want in
do you want to serve your country on the most
important battlefield of the war sir that's all
i want you just got promoted i don't know if i
can do this nothing too sell a few bonds bonds
buy bullets bullets kill nazis bing bang boom
series e defense bonds each one you buy is a
bullet in the barrel of your best guy's gun
i need to volunteer i already volunteered how
do you think i got here bring that the girls
hi what are you doing here schmidt sent out
a force to osama 200 men went up against
him in less than 50 returned your audience
contained what was left of the 107th the 107th
oh my god are you planning a rescue mission
yeah it's called winning the war but if you
know where they are why not at least 30 miles
behind the lines through some of the most
heavily fortified territory in europe we lose
more men and would say but i don't expect you
to understand that because you're a chorus girl
yeah that you made him that what do you plan to
do walk to austria that's what it takes you
heard the colonel your friend is most likely
dead you don't know that even so he's devising
a strategy if he detects by the time he's done
that it could be too late hmm tell me you thought
i was meant for more than this did you mean that
every word you gotta let me go
but i love you
the hydra camp is in crossbow between these
two mountain ranges it's a factory of some
kind agent carter we're not in too much of a
hurry i thought we could stop off in lucerne
for a late night fondue oh god stark is
the best civilian pilot i've ever seen
he's mad enough to brave this airspace we're
lucky to have him so are you two do you
fondue
that's like the first time i've
seen him smile the whole movie
who you supposed to be um captain america
this is like star wars but on earth
no what are you doing i forces are outmatched
mighty stop it's me steve come on
i thought you were smaller
what were they doing dan why
was he on a table like that
what happened to you i joined the army
oh my god
captain america how exciting
i am a great fan of your films
oh dr askin managed it after all
you got no idea
every day
oh oh my god
no matter what life told you you
say i was his greatest success
oh no wonder like he had an awful facelift job
you don't have one of those do you you are
deluded captain villains never have noses
it's so gross
he's all right
senator brandt what
yes i am honored to present this
medal for valor to my personal friend
captain america captain that's your cue i thought
he'd be taller baltic and the sixth one was about
here 30 40 miles west of the maginot line she is
just looking at him like with those bedroom eyes
i want every allied eyeball looking for
that main hydra base i'll need a team
we're already putting together the
best man with all due respect sir
so am i we barely got out of there
alive and you want us to go back
that's rather fun actually i'm in we're in i'll
always fight howard has some equipment for you to
he's a strong guy but not strong enough not to
look down you don't like music i do actually
i might even when this is all over go dancing
then what are we waiting for the right partner
no 800 captain yes ma'am he even looked at
captain i'm looking for mr stark he's in
with colonel phillips of course you're
welcome to wait read about what you did
just doing what needed to be done sounded
like more than that you saved nearly 400 men
be careful with blondes you're a
hero well that you know that that
depends on the definition the women
of america they owe you the thanks
and uh seeing as they're not here no don't
ruin it with agent carter you freaking [__]
captain we're ready for you if you're not
otherwise occupied i'm kidding i don't call
women [__] i was just joking right now you are
just like all the rest well what about you and
stark how do i know you two haven't been fonduing
you still don't know a bloody thing about women
what about this one no no that's just
a prototype what's it made of vibranium
that's the rarest metal on earth what
you're holding there that's all we've got
i'm sure the captain has some
unfinished business what do you think
yes i think it works i had some
ideas about the youtube i like her
i know she has a show i need to watch it
hmm
oh wow
ah
imagine
you are failing we are close to an
offensive that will shake the planet
i know he's supposed to look scary
but he looks just funny to me
i had him on the ropes i know he did watch out
oh don't let go he said hang on why would you like
after all that and saving him dang he
was cute too i'm but doesn't he come back
or something i feel like i've
seen him in something he better
he was too cute to die how much time we got
according to my new best friend under 24
hours where is he now hydra's last base is
here in the alps 500 feet below the circle
it's not like we can just knock on the front
door that's exactly what we're gonna do
okay batman
presented my genius and tried to
deny me what was rightfully mine
but he gave you everything what made you so
special nothing i'm just a kid from brooklyn
why did that piss them all
i can do this all day oh of course you can of
course but unfortunately i am on a tight schedule
so am i
why did he just run off uh like you had um
but he just oh it looked
like he just slipped and fell
fire not
get friends
that looks like fun
there we go
go get him he's about to pass
oh
oh my god oh my god i would ship
bricks if i were either of them
not new york that's where i live
yeah let's hit a bomb
oh my god disney what the oh my god
that was so dumb why would you do that
couldn't they all get like sucked out
of the plane if there's a window open
uh again dumb
we
you just have the power of the dog i
have seen the future cats not my future
what i gotta put her in the water please
don't do this we have time we can work it out
you're gonna need a rain check on that dance
i was wondering why they didn't dance all
right a week next saturday at the stalk club
you got it eight o'clock don't you
i'll show you how just be there
we'll have the band play something
i'd hate to slow on you
steve
steven where am i you're in a recovery room in
new york city where am i really i'm afraid i
don't understand the game it's from may 1941
i know cause i was there cancer rogers wait
hey soldier
you're in the future you thought it best to break
it to you slowly break what you've been asleep cap
for almost 70 years you gonna be
okay yeah yeah i just i had a date
well that was captain america very very different
i will say i was wondering how queensid was going
to do a war movie and so i yeah it's weird like
i've never seen this sort of subject matter
in like a pg or pg-13-ish rating obviously war
movies are usually extremely violent and so yeah
i was i was just really curious the whole time
watching like how far are they gonna go with this
minus that guy going through the freaking
propellers could have done without that scene
but honestly it was pretty enjoyable i just think
they could i honestly feel like they could have
been a little more more gritty with it it seemed
still very polished and obviously the cgi was
noticeable in this movie a lot uh maybe because
it was a little earlier what i don't know what
year this was i mean some of the cgi kind of took
me out of it a little bit i'm not gonna lie like
i saw the green screen in her hair and stuff
like that but other than that it was different
it was different i thought the ending was really
heartfelt i feel like it didn't linger long enough
for me like as i started to get teary-eyed it
just jumped into the future i don't know that
could have lingered more for me but i really liked
that whole sequence where he's about to go under
and he's talking about the date like that really
got me agent carter i love her i feel like
i can really i was not in the army though but
i kind of wish there were there had been a few
more moments between captain america and her
that were good i feel like obviously they had
a lot of attention and stuff and she got mad
at him and that's that was hilarious to me
um because it just seemed natural but i i really
wish there had been just a little bit more with
them to make the ending stronger but i was i
really felt i did feel it though i felt that
they never got their dance that's gonna bother
me that's just really gonna bother me we just
i mean the whole time i'm gonna be watching
the avengers i'm like they don't remember it
and that's so sad and she
died thinking that he was dead
man he's gonna need therapy i honestly just
feel really bad for him like i know he's gonna
be in the avengers i just feel bad for him
like that's a doozy i can see why maybe he'd
be a little angsty he seemed really serious
in this movie he's a very serious character
so i like when we got a few moments where
he smiled and was happy he went through it
so i'm just curious to see how his character
develops and how he handles the modern world
because to be honest i'd be pretty mad too the
villain wasn't that scary to me i feel like again
for a good movie like it's gotta have a good
villain and i feel like obviously i think they
were trying to go with a whole hitler concept with
him where he just wants to watch the world burn
i guess but i don't know that wasn't super
fleshed out for me his motivation obviously
so then the ending kind of felt with the
villain at least it kind of felt a little
abrupt it wasn't like a big payoff for me he was
just like i'm holding it and then i explode i
guess i don't know this just felt like it was more
about captain america than it was about a villain
so i feel that there were aspects about this movie
that i did like i don't know there were a lot of
lines in this movie that i thought were funny and
great like i'm not gonna kiss you that that really
got me i loved that the acting was really great
in this movie i feel like a lot of war movies
focus on the relationships with the soldiers
and the men fighting closely with each other
i think a great example of that is the movie fury
i guess i kind of thought that they were going to
focus a lot maybe on the relationships with the
men that continued to fight with captain america
after he saved their lives and so i i don't know
i guess i just wanted more if that makes sense
like i mean it would have been really great to
explore those other men and why they continued to
fight with captain america and i know he lost his
best friend i just thought they were going to do
more with the other men and that that would have
been a really cool story for like a ween's war
movie this was interesting it achieved its
goal of of tackling this very dark subject
of like nazis for example and making it kid
friendly i just yeah i think they could have gone
a little grittier with it maybe they could have
made it feel a little more like a war movie but
i see why they didn't also like this also worked
i did really love how it was shot i loved the
aesthetic of it i loved that it was very vintage
looking and a lot of the colors were like you know
green tan muted the colors in this movie
and the set decorations and everything
like that it just looked really cool i also
understand now why this wasn't the first movie
i know he's the first avenger technically but
obviously having known the information that i
do now about iron man and his father i now get why
this movie was a little later because now you're
understanding how uh tony stark's father
kind of fits in with this whole world and
how he did help you know basically first start the
avengers is really fascinating and he's kind of a
good guy which is nice i'm sure the tesseract
comes back i get why this movie came a little
later and came after iron man um that was really
interesting this movie had a lot of great lines
cinematography and the fight sequences were fun i
don't remember a lot of the star wars movies to be
honest that'll probably be another series but it
kind of felt star wars-esque to me with the pupil
you know the guns that shoot out lasers but it was
interesting seeing like an old vintage sort of set
but with those that kind of threw me off but i
mean it was also cool it was just a different
atmosphere for sure f4 war movie yeah overall i'm
just really excited to watch the avengers now i
know that everyone was talking about the winter
soldier and civil war is the civil war the other
one i just heard more about those movies than i
did with this one so i'm excited this obviously
is a huge setup for the character so i'm excited
to see the rest of those movies and again to see
how his character develops and how he deals with
all of this trauma adapting to everything it was a
fun movie i i enjoyed all the action even though
i didn't quite understand the science behind
the lasers and the tesseract and all that that
got a little confusing either i'm stupid and
i couldn't follow i follow along lager it
was just seemed a little plot holy to me
but it was fun it could have been a much darker
movie so i loved the aesthetic of this movie it
was really it was really different anyway
if you enjoyed this reaction please give
it a like it does help the algorithm turn on that
notification bell to know when i post the avengers
video that'll be fun and then we'll
be hopping right into phase two
i'm excited i'm super excited and you should
be too america and i'll see you next week